how about our caller from the eight
three two let's go to eight three two
caller from eight three two what's your
name and where you're calling from my in
Bandra Pali from Houston Texas all right
Andrew what's on your mind today
uh yeah browsing two-year-old episodes
and I was wondering uh when one of them
even a interview uh definite or again
yeah the Jesse Ventura interviews have
been funny the thing is he's kind of off
the grid and by that I mean he lives off
the grid that's his thing now in some
part of Mexico and we don't have any
outbound contact info for him it was
always when he had a new book or show
his publicist would get in touch with us
so I don't know how we would get ahold
of the guy I'd be up for having him on
though for sure is an her interviews
have always been entertaining yeah cuz I
really enjoyed that interview or I was
also hoping you might interview a the
Jimmy doors even door so he's also a
very progressive guy so I would love to
see y'all to just talk or would just an
intern yeah okay well Jimmy Dore I don't
know nobody else has suggested that we
have Jimmy door on but that you know I'm
not opposed to having any particular
person on if it makes sense but we will
look into everything Andrew everything
okay in Houston there yeah that's good
that's good alright Andrew thanks for
the call appreciate it